of the Iraq situation and I will
actually come come up to the present
time but I won't be saying very much
about Assyrian monuments because so dr.
prom is going to talk to us about those
well I think the problems in there are
really started during the iraq-iran war
we need to remember that to put the
whole thing into a context iran-iraq
actually had a very good record of
looking after its cultural heritage up
until then probably the best in the
whole of the region but during the war
it didn't have the capacity or the
resources to spend money on conserving
monuments and learning and protecting
archaeological sites so they started to
fall into disrepair and these problems
were exacerbated in during the first
Gulf War in 1991 a number of provincial
museums were ransacked and some
archaeological sites were looted now
unfortunately I think this is all these
are all things that are well known to
many of you unfortunately lessons were
not learn in advance of the Second Gulf
War and coalition troops fail to take
any measures to protect museums or
archaeological sites and as is well
known the iraq museum itself was looted
and some iconic objects such as a very
famous ivory block showing a lioness and
an African are still missing together
with about 8,000
chips from the storerooms and these
include the Arab museums unparalleled
collection of cylinder seals and there
was also at that time some looting
although on a much lesser scale of in
Mosul Museum and at the same time a
number of archaeological sites all in
the south of the country were very bad
diluted and they include places like
pissing OMA a dab of Uhuru and nipper
and photographs of these sites or
surfaces pockmarked with holes rather
like a Swiss cheese or a lunar landscape
a 1k subtracting a great deal of
attention was Babylon but the problem
here was of a different kind there was
it became the site of a coalition
military base known as camp alpha when
it was occupied by coalition troops a
good deal of damage was done and that
was the subject of a detailed report
published by unesco in 2009 so in some
during this period there was a lot of
damage to a rocky cultural heritage but
there were also some positive
developments for example a survey of
archaeological sites in southern Iraq in
june two thousand eight seemed to show
that the looting had more or less stock
by then and the world monuments found
was given a grant of the US State
Department to prepare a detailed survey
and management plan for Babylon then the
iraq museum was able to reopen all its
galleries on our summer and progress is
being made with establishing a new
museum for Basra so it did seem by the
spring of last year that some real
progress
being made and that the worst was over I
think few people could have predicted
the absolute disaster that was about to
befall Iraq on tenth June as you know
Islamic fundamentalist variously known
as Isis or dash over an Mosul I'm not
only introduced to rip that they've
embarked on a program of cultural
destruction is unparalleled in modern
times in Mosul for example in Mosul
itself in the city many famous mosques
and shrines have been obliterated
apparently on the grounds of they
commemorate Saints and other famous
figures which is enough amount of the
fundamentalist interpretation of Sunni
Islam they would buy our Isis and more
than 50 on iconic buildings in Mosul
have been destroyed many of them dating
back to the sixth seventh century AD and
many of them of great historical
significance and this widespread
destruction has actually gone largely
unnoticed by the Western media but when
we consider that there were more
historical monuments in Mosul than in
any other city in Iraq the scale of the
disaster don't start to become unclear
well of course a favorite tactic of Isis
is the release of propaganda videos I
expect you've all seen I understand from
Vernon that a policy was decision a
policy decision was taken not to show
any of them
and I agree with that but just to say
that the first one released in late
februari showed the Smashing of stone
statues and reliefs in Mosul Museum
there were some Assyrian pieces and some
statues from the caravan city of Petra
and it's unfortunate that early reports
about the damage in Mosul Museum
suggested that all the pieces which had
been damaged or some of them were costs
that was certainly not the case of about
50 pieces in the museum only a half
dozen or so were actually cost so their
disruption is a very significant loss
for our cultural heritage and it's a
tragic loss for future generations of
visitors to Mosul Museum and that same
video show these fanatics attacking
Assyrian human-headed wing Bulls in the
narrow gate at nuna fee I'm not
proposing to say anything about nimrood
a horrific video released last Saturday
showed you
the very very extensive damage that has
been at the apple site and anybody who
have hardly the strength to watch the
video through to the end will see that
the site of the Northwest College Sasha
not supposed palace of nimrood is
nothing more now than a pile of rubble I
don't want to speculate too much here
about the motivation of those involved
in this awful cultural vandalism but in
recent in the recent year in the last
year the sale of Antiquities doesn't
seem to have been high on the list of
priorities as if it was presumably the
these hooligans wouldn't have been
smashing them I just like to conclude
very briefly by suggesting a few things
that might be done I know it's a subject
to this afternoon session but I just
like to very briefly touch on this now
in my own view the most important thing
is that the United Nations UNESCO and
the international community should put
pressure on those individuals and our
governments who are thought to be
sponsoring Isis put pressure on them to
stop supplying money and facilitating
what they're doing but also
issue statements condemning these
actions the second thing to be done is
as obvious it's a given which is to
enforce existing regulations and
legislation about the trafficking of of
antiquities as I said I don't think has
been the motivation for this recent
disruption but it's certainly true that
the new ting of archaeological sites
from 2003 onwards was was was in order
to attain antiquities for sale on the
market the third thing to be done I'm I
think this is obvious to everybody is to
is more education about the value of
cultural heritage inside and outside the
country confusing question and the
fourth thing is to for the international
community to provide assistance but I
have to say this is more difficult if
and when the Iraq government does
recover the occupied areas is going to
need large sums of money to tackle the
problems on an army of architectural
conservators restorers and so on a huge
international relief effort will
obviously be needed thank you